daredevil is back but a little different
this time as exciting as it is to see
jennifer walters as the green tinted
she-hulk attorney at law there's another
jurist hero that fans are likewise eager
to see turn up in the new disney plus
series as teased in trailers leading up
to the latest chapter in the marvel
cinematic universe the mcu's newest
lawyer is set to face off against a
familiar one matt murdock also known as
daredevil played once again by charlie
cox from the netflix daredevil series
following his appearance in spider-man
no way home i'm a really good lawyer the
final trailer for she-hulk attorney at
law confirmed that murdoch would
re-emerge as the horn-headed vigilante
fans fell in love with during his stint
on his netflix series the writers of
she-hulk made a daring move introducing
the hero of hell's kitchen director kat
koiro told entertainment weekly i am
definitely excited for daredevil to make
his appearance because i think he's
going to be a crowd favorite but it
turns out the devil was in the details
regarding murdoch's return one detail
specifically speaking to life hackers
she hulk writer jessica gal revealed
that marvel gave the creative team a
surprising level of freedom when they
put in their request for matt murdock to
appear on the series she explained when
they first told us that daredevil was a
possibility we just couldn't believe it
and as we were coming up with story and
what we wanted him to do the fact that
they kept not saying no was shocking to
us the one area that the writers got no
say in was daredevil's costume gao said
the one thing that i didn't have control
of was the suit they knew exactly what
they wanted the suit to look like from
what we've seen so far daredevil's
current appearance does largely match
the costume charlie cox wore in the
netflix series but the extra bit of
flair comes from the inclusion of yellow
which is a callback to the color combo
that debuted in daredevil's first six
issues before he switched to all red
gow told collider that many characters
were unavailable for inclusion in
she-hulk due to conflicts with other mcu
properties at first she assumed that the
same was true of daredevil but the
writing team soon found out otherwise
gow said we thought we were being
pranked we just kept writing him in and
we kept rolling with the story just
thinking like okay any moment now
they're going to tell us we can't use
them they made a mistake they actually
don't have the rights but it just kept
becoming more and more real in july of
2022 marvel studios revealed that it's
in the process of working on a new
daredevil series titled daredevil born
again it's entirely possible that his
appearance in she-hulk will serve as a
prelude to his upcoming starring vehicle
could the fact that his suit is now
somewhat different in appearance suggest
we're dealing with a different devil
than the one who exclaimed in 2018 i
beat you or is this merely a new chapter
for an established character we'll leave
jen to find that out as she-hulk
continues